So, guck ob alles funzt, ah sieht gut aus, POG, POG, POG, POG, so, die Modes gehen nicht,
wir Champions, ah doch, oin Baby Clocks, yep Clocks,
jetzt meine Vm einschalten, die brauchen wir bestimmt. Ich habe heute aufgeräumt und ich
habe alles in eine große Kiste geschmissen, was nicht gerade kompletter Müll war und das
müssen wir einschalten, ja, also was nicht Verpackung und kompletter Müll war. Ich habe
einfach alles mal in eine Kiste geschmissen und jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, was ich behalten
kann und was nicht. Es hat überhaupt keinen tieferen Sinn, EL aufräumen. Ich habe alles
in eine große Kiste geschmissen, also um ehrlich zu sein, es ist nicht eine große Kiste, es sind
eins, zwei, drei, vier Kisten, gibt es Handicam, ja, gibt es, klar gibt es Handicam, Bäm, hallo,
Wave, so und ja wir gucken mal, ein Kurs für Shit, wie stellst du dir das vor? Wie stellst
du dir einen Kurs vor für Shit? Weiß natürlich, was du meinst, aber was soll ich da für einen
Kurs machen? Zu Git gibt es doch schon 30.000 Milliarden Kurse. 13 Jahre Abo-Falle, so muss
es sein, da werde ich jetzt reich, Poggers, danke für den Sub. Nein, das habe ich nicht
gesehen, aber ich habe schon andere Control-F Dokus gesehen, mit teilweise fragwürdigem
Inhalt, wo ich mir gedacht habe, na ob das mal so stimmt, also gut, kann man nicht unbedingt
verallgemeinern, das kenne ich nicht. So, also, weil letztes Mal ein paar Leute da sind,
die Musik ist ein bisschen laut, oder? Passt eigentlich. Passt, wunderbar. So eine Videoreise
für kleines Geld von dir, wie man sowas deploit. Ähm, ich glaube, bin ich nicht der Richtige
für so Tutorials. Also, jetzt mal an alle, ich habe zu einem schon gesagt, ich habe heute
aufgeräumt bei mir hier ein bisschen, ich hatte noch sehr viel Zeug, ich habe ja auch
total viel bei Amazon bestellt, es hat sich das Zeug gestapelt und ich habe jetzt mal
wirklich nicht alles, aber vieles aufgeräumt und habe alles, was nicht Packung ist, alles,
was nicht Verpackung ist, habe ich genommen und habe es in vier große, ich sage jetzt
einfach mal in eine große Kiste geschmissen. Und wir gucken jetzt einfach mal, was da so
dabei ist und ich muss gucken, dass ich keine Adressen Leaks mache oder so und was ich davon
behalte oder nicht. Manches ist schon ein bisschen verstaubt, guckt mal hier, zum Beispiel
manche Sachen sind schon ein bisschen, ich muss mal kurz checken, nicht, dass da irgendwie
Aufkleber drauf ist mit Adresse oder so, ah nee, China-Chinesen-Aufkleber ist drauf,
zum Beispiel hier sowas, man sieht, das lag schon etwas länger, wenn man sich hier den
Staub drauf an, erkennt man den Staub überhaupt? Hier, guckt euch das mal an, das ist mega
staubig, das lag in echt in der hintersten Ecke jetzt irgendwie für zwei Jahre und ich
habe da einiges heute gefunden, wo ich mich teilweise selbst frage, was es ist und das
gucken wir uns heute mal an. Was jetzt? Ok, wait, ah, ich weiß, was es ist, ich habe vergessen
den Strom anzuschließen, äh, wie kriege ich denn das Handy jetzt entsperrt, wie kriege
ich das Handy, das muss ich noch mal raus machen, ok, ich muss euch mal kurz ausschalten,
damit ich das Handy nochmal neu adjusten kann, ohne dass man hier, geht das wieder? Ok, ich
glaube, ich muss neu laden, das ist jetzt etwas painstärm, weil ich mich selbst in
der Frontkamera sehe, oh, ups, das habe ich Mist gemacht, Leute, lull, leak, leak, start,
ok, ich habe es gleich, dass wir die Kamera wieder aufhängen, so und jetzt sollte es eigentlich
wieder funzen, ja, Pog, es geht wieder, ihr seht aber glaube ich noch nichts, Moment,
lull, ok, wunderbar, funzt wieder, hide controls, ok, geht wieder, sehr schön, leak, ja, man
sieht mich, oh nein, in der schwarzen, im schwarzen Bildschirm sieht man mich, ja, übrigens
Leute, wisst ihr, was ich hier gerade noch stehen habe? Richtig, richtig nice P-Pro-Fat-Time,
ich muss das Kabel hier irgendwie weg machen, so, jetzt einmal eine Runde P-Pro-Fat kurz
hier, ich muss jetzt mal, rote jetzt mal weg, jaja chat, hau rein, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ja, gleich geht es los, ja, ok, ok, ok, ok, krasch, krasch, krasch, krasch, ok, ok, ok,
Ich denke du wolltest abnehmen, wer sagte das, wenn ich schon längst abgenommen hab?
So, aufräumt Champ am Start, also fangen wir mal an, ich hab keine Ahnung was ich da
ausgebuddelt hab, doch ich weiß es, ich hab schon reingeguckt.
So, und erstmal hier Pepofed ausblenden, also, wie gesagt, ich hab vier große Kartons
hier mit Zeugs was ich heute quasi festgestellt hab am aufräumen, bin ich mir noch nicht
sicher ob ich's wegschmeiße und das gucken wir uns heute mal an, das wird kein super
high octane stream oder so, einfach gucken, so was ist das hier, giveaway, das da oben
ist übrigens die hall of shame, das sind alle dinger die ich schon im stream dieses
Jahr kaputt gemacht hab, ein controller steils, so also was haben wir denn hier, so das zeug
staubig, boah, alter, das ist so staubig das die kamera leckt, boah, alter kam riesen,
ich weiß nicht inwieweit ihr das gesehen habt, da kam gerade ein riesen staubding, alter,
das stand wirklich in der allerhintersten ecke, ich sag's euch, erstmal maske aufziehen,
so was haben wir denn hier so, das china chinesen usb kabel und so dinger, ich glaub ich weiß
was das ist leute, das ist eine raspberry pi usb wenn ich nicht komplett falsch liege,
hab doch irgendwo ne schere, ach kacke, wer braucht ne schere hier, einfach hier, bam,
ich glaub das ist ne raspberry pi usb, also die packung kommt auf jeden fall schonmal
weg, so also wenn ich das richtig in erinnerung habe, war das, muss kurz mein headset ein
bisschen umhängen, das ist nicht so an der Jacke schleift hier, wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere ist das ne raspberry pi usb und das ist so gedacht, dass man der einen seite,
aber den kram mal ab, ne, das hab ich nämlich mal bei aliexpress bestellt im 10er pack,
das ist die box noch, hier kommt so ne batterie rein, so ne, hier guck mal, 18650, das ist
so was wie ne zikaretten reinkommt und so was, so ein akku, akku besser gesagt, ist der
der reinkommt und dann machst du hier, hast du hier input, hast du hier output, hier kannst
du ne raspberry pi reinstecken und dann passt das, ich hab jetzt, ich hab jetzt leider nichts
da, ich glaub das hab ich auch schonmal in einem anderen video gezeigt, ich hab leider
weder ne batterie dafür da noch sonst wie was, dass wir das großartig ausprobieren
konnten, ich würd einfach sagen, ja, ich geh mal davon aus, das funktioniert noch,
das ding nicht in auto ist, keine ahnung, wüsste ich jetzt nicht, mark ldm, dankeschön,
mein handy, mein handy ist die kamera gerade in in use, aber ich hab halt keine batterie
dafür, um das auszubrüsten, egal, ist eh nicht so spektakulär, was haben wir als nächstes
hier, so, was, was, was ist hier alles, also lasst mal kurz checken, ein staubiger shelly
und zwar ein shelly, was für einer ist das, ein shelly 1pm, wifi relay switch mit power
metering, metering, metering, also power metering, also dass man halt einfach gucken kann, wieviel
das verbraucht, das zeug was dran hängt, 16 ampere version, ok, ich kann mich gar nicht
daran erinnern, dass ich jemals ein shelly 1pm bestellt hab, aber anscheinend hab ich
mal ein shelly 1pm bestellt, gucken wir mal rein, was wir heute machen, ganz einfach,
ich hab vorhin aufgeräumt und hab alles, was ich nicht instant wegschmeißen wollte, in
sagen wir mal in eine große kiste geschmissen und wir gucken uns mal an, was das alles ist,
ob sich das lohnt aufzuheben, keine ahnung, du siehst ja auch schon, es hat teilweise
einen staub angesetzt, so zeig mal her, shelly, komm an, zeig uns, aha, guck mal, der ist
rot, das war auch schon mal auf, würde ich sagen, sonst hätte das irgendwo drinnen
gesteckt, so, ups, wie alt das ist, oh, also das zeug, was ich hier hab, kann so 2-3 jahre
alt sein oder relativ neu, ich hab hier Kartons aus allen, boah das staub hier alter, Kartons
aus allen möglichen letzten der 3 jahre drin, so also haben wir hier einmal nen shelly, da,
kann man zeug anschließen, wer die dinger gar nicht kennt, das sind Sachen, die kann
man in die Steckdose, also nicht in die Steckdose, ist falsch, dort wo Lichtschalter sind, in
diese Dosen kann man das einbauen und dann kann man Lichtschalter oder halt generell,
alles was ihr mit diesem Schalter so schaltet, kann man dann über das Wlan schalten und
mit dem Schalter, also sprich, man siehts hier, ja guck mal, man sieht hier unten auch die
Anschlüsse, also, so, an SW kannst du den normalen Schalter anschließen, alter was,
was geht mit meinem Handy ab, man, was denn das für ein Scheiß, was hat das für Probleme,
warum schaltet sich das immer aus, das hat es doch das letzte Mal nicht gemacht, was
ist das für ein Kack, das ist ja Müll, ich hab die letzten Streams immer mit dem Handy
genommen, Handy müde, ja genau, das versteh ich nicht, hoffen wir, dass es jetzt funktioniert,
wenn das nicht geht, hab ich ein Problem, dann muss ich mir echt mal ne richtige Kamera
zulegen, das ist ja auch nicht schlimm, ich mach das nochmal komplett zu, also angeblich
lädts und wie gesagt, ich will nicht, dass es lädt, weil wenn es lädt, dann stürzt
es ab oder so ähnlich, ich mach jetzt einfach nochmal neu auf dieses Sharing Programm
und ihr seht nix, das ist normal, weil ich mich nicht Monka League machen will, allow,
select audio source, kein audio, frontkamera, nein, backkamera, start, so, jetzt hoff ich
mal, jetzt hoff ich einfach mal, dass es so bleibt, wenn es nicht bleibt, hab ich echt
ein Problem, dann kann ich den Stream nicht machen, mach euch wieder an, keine Ahnung,
was das für ein Mist ist, naja, zumindest, von der Idee her ist das so, an SW schließt
ihr den normalen Schalter an, an die anderen Sachen muss man sich das Diagramm genau angucken,
das was ihr schalten wollt, dann könnt ihr beispielsweise das Licht an der Decke ein
und ausschalten, übers WLAN und weiterhin mit dem Schalter, das ist gut, weil es gibt
Leute, die stehen unglaublich auf Schalter, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn ihr Frau,
Freundin, Mutter, Opa, Oma, wen auch immer habt, die mögen Schalter, die mögen nicht
so sehr Apps auf dem Handy, mit denen ihr schaltet, das ist das beste aus zwei Welten, du kannst
quasi übers Handy ein und ausschalten und übers Schalter ein und ausschalten, exellent.
Handy müde, Handy schlafen, ja, so, das ist das, das behalte ich auf jeden Fall, den kann
man noch mal gut gebrauchen, behalte Champ, ich brauche, bräuchte eigentlich noch eine
Kiste, wo ich alles, was ich behalten will, reinschmeiße, ich bin auch über 30, ich bin
37, mag keine Schalter, ich hoffe, also ohne Scheißlaut, ich hoffe, dass das bleibt an,
wenn das nicht anbleibt, ist echt dumm, so, was haben wir als nächstes noch, wir haben
noch einen, Konbi Stick, Version 1, Konbi ZigBee Gateway, den brauche ich eigentlich
nicht, hallo Kamera, kannst du dich scharf stellen, ist das möglich, den brauche ich
nicht, Kamera, eben hast du dich doch schon, ja, perfekt, weil ich habe schon Konbi 2,
also wozu brauche ich noch einen Konbi 1, das ist, wenn man ZigBee Geräte hat und einen
ZigBee Gateway, ZigBee Hostdings Adapter, wie auch immer, das heißt, sind die Dinger
echt gut, aber es gibt mittlerweile schon Konbi 2, Verlosung, ne, ich habe nichts verlost,
also ich brauche mal irgendwo eine Kiste, wobei, schläg es einfach, schläg es einfach
neben hin, also den werde ich auch auf jeden Fall behalten, so, was haben wir denn hier
sonst noch, eine 64G Samsung Micro SD, ja natürlich, die behalte ich auch, warum soll ich die nicht
behalten, so, und jetzt ist die Frage, was ist da drin, lass mich mal kurz reingucken,
hast du irgendwas mit, ok, da ist sehr unspektakulär drin, außer, dass es staubig ist, da ist Noctua
Shit drin, was keiner mehr braucht, guck mal, das braucht wirklich, und aus irgendwelchen
Gründen ein HDMI Kabel, das gehört aber zum Noctua nicht dabei, eins muss man den Noctua
Dinger lassen, die sind immer richtig krass verpackt, oder, da war mal ein Lüfter drin
und hier ist das ganze Zubehör noch am Start, von irgendwelchen Schrauben bis, keine Ahnung,
Leute, braucht man sowas nochmal, was, was mein ihr, sollte man das aufheben oder nicht,
ich mein, eigentlich ist es ziemlich unsinnig, weil bei jedem Noctua Lüfter ist ja der ganze
Shit auch wieder dabei, nimmt kein Platz, naja, kann man weitermachen, dass es keinen
Platz wegnimmt, zumindest ist es ja uninteressant, das schieben wir einfach mal wieder rein,
Kacibas, weg damit, bleibst du an Handy, ich tippe einfach alle 5 Minuten, Chat, ihr könnt
mich daran erinnern, ich tippe jetzt einfach alle 5 Minuten hier aufs Handy drauf, dass
es anbleibt, um auf Nummer sicher zu gehen, so, ok, das war die erste kleine Ladung, jetzt
kommt die ganze Kiste, ich brauche Platz, Leute, ich weiß nicht, wo ich es hin machen
soll, ich brauche eine leere Kiste, ich habe jede Menge Kisten, aber keine leere Kiste,
wir machen einfach eine Kiste, aber wir machen jetzt einfach eine Kiste leer, ok Leute, nächste
Kiste, was nehmen wir jetzt, exellent, die Kiste hier, passbar auf, so, da ist ein bisschen
was drin, minimal, das heißt ich brauche Platz, ich hänge mal kurz meine Headsets um, dass
ich die hier auf meinen Schreibtisch stellen kann, ohne dass ich mein Trinken umschmeiße,
so, also ich habe jede Menge von solchen, wie gesagt, ich habe 4 solche Kisten voll
und auch eine große, also das erste was ich hier schon mal sehe ist, ziemlich useless,
wie nennt man das eigentlich genau, hat irgendjemand einen Plan, irgendetwas mit Schellen oder
so, Rohrschelle oder so, Rohrschelle, Schraubenschelle, zumindest, die Dinger sind sehr praktisch,
wenn man was festmachen muss, also das ist anscheinend irgendein Set mit vielen verschiedenen,
da kann man, wenn man ein bisschen besser Schrauben dreht, guck, da kann man die so, die ziehen
sich dann fest mit der Zeit, so, kann man das zusammenschrauben, gut, Leute, ich hole
mir mal eine Kiste, wo ich das alles reinschmeißen kann, ich brauche mal schnell eine bisschen
größere Kiste, rein pfeffern, nicht runterfallen, nein, nein, nein, und Kässe,
so, ich habe eine Kiste gefunden, gut, also das
brauche ich auf jeden Fall aus, auf ist bestimmt praktisch, so, was haben wir als nächstes
da drinnen, irgendeine schaltbare Steckdose, warte mal, wartet mal kurz, ich glaube wir
sind ein bisschen weit jetzt unten, so, ein bisschen, ok, so, das ist irgendeine schaltbare
Steckdose, aber ich glaube das ist keine geflashte, ich glaube das ist eine Z-Wave Steckdose,
gucken wir mal, kennt man das, das ist eine Cyro's Technology GmbH Smart Plug und dann
erkennt das irgendwer, das ist so hell vom Licht, Zub, Zub, was für ein Teil, Zubkirr,
das ist glaube ich eine Z-Wave Steckdose, bin ich mir relativ sicher, schauen wir mal
schnell, ich glaube das ist eine Z-Wave Steckdose, schauen wir mal, Cyro's, Zub, Zub, Zub und
dann eins eins irgendwas oder so, ah hier, guck mal, exellent, exellent, das ist das
Teil, ok, das ist eine Z-Wave Steckdose mit zweimal USB, ok, nooo, ist wieder ausgegangen,
ok Leute, mit dem Stream wird heute nichts, mein Handy ist in der Meinung sich ausschalten
zu müssen, ich weiß nicht warum, das hat das vorher nie gemacht, ich weiß nicht warum,
keine Ahnung, vielleicht iOS 15, ich glaube es ist iOS 15, Stromsparnmodus, ist das irgendeine
iOS 15, Leute ihr wisst das doch bestimmt, gab es mit iOS 15 irgendeine Neuerung, was
mit Strom sparen und zeuschen geht, weil normalerweise ist das per Videoübertragung immer angeblieben,
tja, dann, machen wir Display Timeout hoch, Settings, schauen wir mal, muss ich mal kurz
gucken, wie mache ich denn Stromsparnmodus überhaupt aus, normalerweise ging das immer
instant, Energy, Energy, wo macht man das überhaupt, ich weiß nicht ob das Log, irgendwas
mit Log, Log Sound, Autolog, Display Autolog ist aus, 30, der steht auf 30 Sekunden, das
ist es schonmal nicht, 30 Sekunden, da müssen wir jetzt mal Google befragen, iOS 15 Log
Screen, While Video, While Video Call, Auto, was, also es muss doch mit iOS 15 sein, weil
mit iOS 14 hat es das noch nicht gemacht, keine Ahnung, also normalerweise hat es immer,
weil das ist ja quasi ein Videocall, hat es den Videocall immer was, immer angelassen,
Video, ok, ja, zeig her, ah, diese bescheuerten, why does my iPhone auto log when I'm in a
video call, ja, ja, freu mich auch, mein Gott, die App, diese Antworten sind so unglaublich
unhilfreich, wie es nur sein kann, ja ok Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich da machen soll,
also das ist natürlich bescheuert, weil, ich kann ja vielleicht alle 5 Minuten das iPhone
Endsperren, was, was könnte man da noch einstellen, Auto log ist auf 30 Sekunden, was es halt
definitiv nicht macht, sondern nach 5 Minuten loggt das, kann man irgendwie, kann man irgendwas
einschalten, irgendwas, keine Ahnung, von, von do not disturb bis, bis sonst wie was,
Fokus, ich share doch mein Screen, alter, lull, was meinste denn, was ich mache, ich
share mein Screen, das geht trotzdem, was, das ist wahrscheinlich irgendein Bug, kann
ich ein iOS Update machen, ist das irgendwas komisches, Software Update, nö, iOS 15.1,
stopp, das scheint, Leute, ich share mal den Sound, ich share mal den Sound mit, vielleicht
gehts dann, probieren wir das mal aus, share camera, allow, sound, ja ja, front camera,
back camera, gachi bass, hallo, ah, jetzt das Sound doppelt geshared, ok, das ist verwirrend,
ich mach das einfach beim Playback aus, lull, wie es das anhört, ok, Stromsparmodus, wo
mache ich den Stromsparmodus aus, kann jetzt nicht alle Settings durchsuchen, so, jetzt
das Echo weg, ok, soll ich jetzt wirklich noch mal raus, Einstellungen, Batterie gucken,
ok, weil ihr es seid, Leute, Einstellungen, Batterie, ich guck nochmal, also, so, Settings,
Batterie, Low Power Mode, der ist aus, da ist kein Low Power Mode an, Low Power Mode
ist aus, Battery Health, Optimized Battery Charging, ne, ne, ne, ne, ok, bringt nichts,
ist alles aus, Screen Lock Time, ne, das kann ich bei mir nur auf 5 Minuten hochstellen,
so, wir probieren das jetzt einfach nochmal, keine Ahnung, aber das ist auf jeden Fall
Paynes Champ, es hängt doch am Ladegerät, Leute, meint ihr, ich bin der letzte Scheiß-Noob
oder was, natürlich hängt es am Ladegerät, ja, guckt da, ich hab das so gesetupet wie
immer und bisher ging das auch immer, das muss irgendein neues iOS 15 Feature sein,
weil mit iOS 14 lief einfach die ganze Geschichte ohne Probleme, vielleicht muss man Safari
auch Fullscreen machen oder so, aber ich hab da nie Einstellungen gehabt, das ging einfach
immer, ja, das ist doof, so, schauen wir mal, gucken wir mal, ob es jetzt was funktioniert,
gibt es ein GitHub Issue, ganz, mach ich starte da doch nichts neu, so, gucken wir mal, ob
ich mich noch doppelt höre, Test, Test, ja, pock, vielleicht bringt das ja was, ok, wo
sind wir stehen geblieben?
Deswegen Android, ja, genau, weil du damit dann keine Probleme hast, das ist doch Schwachsinn,
das irgendwie da drauf zu schieben, so, naja, machen wir mal weiter, mal gucken, außerdem
noch ein weiterer Grund, ich muss den Kram nicht selbst bezahlen, also warum sollte ich
mir was anderes holen, ok, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, also Z-Wave USB, Z-Wave Steckdose,
ja behalte ich auf jeden Fall, haben wir das hier mal rein, Rums, Next, was, haha, guck
du mal was ich als nächstes hab, lull, ein eingestaubter USB Ventilator, warum ich das
hab, keine Ahnung, weil, USB Ventilator, guckt mal hier, wartet mal, weg, oh guck mal, der
geht noch nicht mal mehr, aber da hat es noch einen Einschalter hinten, hier, ein USB Ventilator,
braucht man sowas reichlich sinnlos oder, ach hab ich euch gar nicht eingeschaltet,
Leute sagt doch was, lull, ich dachte ihr seht die ganze Zeit schon was, ich dachte ihr seht
die ganze Zeit was, sagt doch was Leute, guckt mal hier USB Ventilator, also das ist schon
ziemlich schwachsinnig, aber plays nice, gachibas, das behalte ich, das ist nice, ich weiß zwar
nicht wozu ich es brauche, aber USB Ventilator ist POG, Massive POG USB Ventilator, kann
man immer mal gebrauchen, ne, Raspberry Pi kühlen oder so, genau, was haben wir hier
als nächstes, ein RM Mini 3, die Dinger sind wirklich richtig nice, wobei der RM Mini
3, der ist bestimmt schon 4 Jahre alt oder so, weiß auch nicht warum ich da noch irgendwo
einen rumfliegen hab, das ist ein Infrarot Sender Empfänger, damit kann man zum Beispiel
Klimaanlagen und sowas fernsteuern, allerdings mit Custom Software, nicht mit dieser komischen
mitgelieferten App, das ist so ein kleiner schwarzer, so eine kleine schwarze Tonne,
versuch mal ob ich es aufkrieg ohne dass ich es kaputt mache, zu spät, USB, ja guckt mal
hier, so eine kleine schwarze Tonne, ach oh Leak, Leak, irgendwo hier ist Infrarot, Stelz
drinnen, hier wahrscheinlich und da gibt es Custom Software für, damit kann man Mitsubishi
Klimaanlagen und sowas steuern, das ist sehr praktisch das Teil, das wird auf jeden Fall
aufgehoben, wisst ihr was, ich kann mal kurz was gucken wegen dem Zeug warum meine Kamera
immer ausgeht, schauen einfach mal, OBS, Ninja, GitHub, da gibt es, ah ne, das hat sich ja
umbenannt, Issues, da gucken wir einfach mal, ob es da ein Issue gibt, Lock, dass es irgendeinen
Bug gibt, gibt es nix, machst du nix, so, was haben wir denn als nächstes, lasst mal,
ach du Scheiße, was habe ich denn hier am Start, was war, was ging denn hier in mir vor,
schaut mal, Mikro SD Karten, warum habe ich 100.000 Mikro SD Karten, das sind, wie viele
sind denn das, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11 und noch ne Samsung, 12, einfach mal
12 Mikro SD Karten, also ich hab hier einige Raspberry Pis und Zeug am Start, aber was
ich damit vor hatte, erzieht sich meiner Kenntnis, ja, das ist richtig, Amazon hat mir mal falsch
geschickt, aber Amazon hat mir mal diese hier falsch geschickt, da hab ich nämlich nur
einen bestellt und Amazon hat mir einen 10er Pack geschickt, das sind andere, keine Ahnung,
aber die behalte ich auf jeden Fall, das sind zwar nur 16G Karten, aber ich mein, für
einen Raspberry Pi, 16G Karten langen eigentlich mehr oder weniger für alles aus, so, weg damit,
bam in die Eck, next, was haben wir denn sonst hier noch, aha, das ist nice, das hatten
wir schon mal im Stream, Leute, ich hab's schon wieder komplett vergessen, dass wir
das mal hatten, hat noch irgendjemand eine Ahnung, was das ist, wird keiner mal wissen,
aber ich weiß es noch, ich zeig's euch mal, guckt mal, das ist ein USB, ein USB Schalter,
mit WLAN, ein WLAN USB Schalter, guckt mal, wenn ihr genau guckt, solltet ihr sehen, dass
da drinnen ein, oh ne, das erkennt man nicht, ne, ne, das sieht man nicht, da ist ein ESP
2866 drinnen, das schwarze da in der Mitte, ähm, und da kann man das Motor oder irgendwas
drauf installieren und dann hat man einen Schalt, einen WLAN schaltbaren USB Schalter,
das ist cool, das hebe ich auf jeden Fall auf, wahrscheinlich hebe ich alles auf, ich
seh's schon, ich seh's schon kommen, dass mein Berg an Sachen trotzdem nicht kleiner
wird, weil das ist, das ist sehr praktisch, das ist nice, das behalte ich, so, was haben
wir denn hier, ok, ein, ein Ploieti Pop-Schutz, der staubig ist, ich glaube, das ist das
erste, was ich entsorge, weg, brauchen wir nicht mehr, so, was haben wir hier als nächstes,
einen, einen ziemlich lidierten Raspberry Pi, ähm, mit, mit Kamera dran, ich weiß,
was es ist, es war die Kamera, die ich mal an meinem 3D-Drucker hatte vor zwei Jahren,
deswegen ist, da hat es da hinten auch diesen Klett, Klettverschluss dran, so und das ist,
das muss ein 3er sein, glaube ich, lasst mal kurz gucken, Raspberry Pi, gucken wir mal,
das ist ein Raspberry Pi 3 Model 2015, ok, das liegt hier schon ein bisschen rum, Glitter-Rost,
danke für den Sub, ja, das hebe ich auf jeden Fall auf, wobei, ob das, Leute, guckt mal,
meint ihr, das Kabel geht noch, das hat hier schon ziemlich gelitten, müssen wir mal ausprobieren,
ist auch, ist auch mit, guck mal, mit 64 Gigabyte Micro SD gerade drin noch, also, ob das noch
funktioniert, äh, fragwürdig, fragwürdig, aber der Raspberry Pi wird auf jeden Fall
noch funktionieren, also, das heben wir natürlich auf jeden Fall auf, Raspberry Pis kann man
nicht genug haben, die Kamera, also, ich weiß nicht, dieses Kabel hat wirklich schon bessere
Tage gesehen, hier, guckt mal, seht ihr das, also, ich glaube, das Kabel ist RIP, aber
der Raspberry Pi wird noch funktionieren, ui, Fischer, danke für den Sub, das heben
wir aber auf jeden Fall auf, Raspberry Pis kann man nie genug haben, so, next, was haben
wir als nächstes, oh, Legacy-Technologie, Leute, Legacy-Technologie, ich muss es erstmal
raus, raus bekommen hier, ok, ich mache einfach den Klumpen, ich, ich nehme einfach den Klumpen
hier rüber, so, Legacy-Technologie, Legacy-Technologie, DVI-Kabel, ich glaube, das kann jetzt im Jahr
2021 echt mal weg, oder was sagt ihr, braucht kein Mensch mehr, oder, wann habt ihr das
letzte Mal mal, mal Realtalk, wann habt ihr das letzte Mal DVI angeschlossen, das bestimmt
schon 5 Jahre her, mindestens, hätt noch, Dankeschön für den Sub, da wurde irgendwie
gehostet oder so, so viele Leute auf einmal, also so viele Subscribes, Subs, Subscriptions
oder so, hab ich was, hab ich was übersehen, oh, Grüne Pizza hat auch gesubbt, Dankeschön,
Lollmann auch, Leute, ich hab ja die Hälfte nicht gesehen, danke, danke, Leute, für die
ganzen Subs, du schaust den Stream über DVI, lull, ernsthaft, nee, DVI kommt weg, ganz
ehrlich, DVI-Kabel brauche ich 2021 wirklich nicht mehr, so, dann haben wir hier noch
einen Switch, den kenne ich noch, der ist gar nicht so alt, den wollte ich eigentlich mal
verlosen, hab ich aber nie gemacht, das ist sogar ein ziemlich guter, das ist ein 10 Gigabit
Switch, 10 Gigabit, ach guck mal, und 2 SFP, alter, 2 Module sogar drinne, jetzt weiß ich
auch, wo der ganze Shit hin ist, ich hab letztens Module gesucht, jetzt weiß ich, wo die
alle sind, die stecken alle hier drin, hier dann, das ist ein ziemlich guter, das ist
ein echt ziemlich guter Switch, den würde ich heute auch noch empfehlen zu kaufen, man
bekommt 5, nee, 4 SFP+, 10G-Ports, dann 1G-Port und jetzt kommt der Hit, dualen Netzteil,
das ist richtig gut das Ding, kostet auch nicht viel, kostet nur 140 Euro oder so, also
es dürfte preisleistungsmäßig eines der interessantesten 10G-Switches sein, so, und
ich habe schon ein paar Glasfaserkabel, weil, warum auch nicht, ne, normalerweise sollte
man übrigens diese Kabels mit so einer Protection vorne drauf haben, aber naja, YOLO, gut,
den behalte ich auf jeden Fall, der kommt bestimmt nicht weg, der bleibt hier, Microtick-Switch,
ja, so, dann haben wir noch ein Raspberry Pi Netzteil, 5,1 Volt, 3 Ampere, typisches
Raspberry Pi Netzteil, sogar ein aktuelles, guck mal, das ist eins mit, muss fürs Vierer
sein, muss ich mal einen Raspberry Pi 4, mit einem der Raspberry Pi 4s gekauft haben,
das heben wir auf, so, das nächste kann wahrscheinlich weg, das nächste ist ein PS, was ist denn das,
ein PS3 oder ein PS4, das ist ein PS4, oder, was ist denn ein Vierer, was ist ein Vierer,
mit diesem komischen Ding da hinten, erkennt man ja hinten, steht ja wieder nix drauf,
ja, ne, den hebe ich auf, ich werde meine PS4 wahrscheinlich nie wieder anschließen,
aber, wenn doch, dann brauche ich ja dann Controller für, und sei es nur, dass man
die mal irgendwie Home-Pro fleschen kann in 5 Jahren oder so, hebe ich auf jeden Fall
auf, kommt in die Kiste, so, was haben wir als nächstes hier, jetzt kann ich, ich stelle
die Kiste einfach mal rüber, so, was haben wir denn sonst noch schönes drin, fokussieren
please, fokussieren, nein, das ist falsch fokussiert, richtig fokussieren, richtig fokussieren,
exellent, so, was haben wir denn hier alles für Zeug, Lüfter, Noctua Lüfter, viel Staub
auf jeden Fall, fleschen geht jetzt schon, mit PS4, keine Ahnung, habe ich nicht verfolgt,
so, wir haben eine alte Elgato Game Capture HD von 2000, keine Ahnung, 12 oder so, das
ist die alte mit 30 FPS nur, glaub unten HDMI-Kabel, das braucht man nicht wirklich,
aber die hebe ich allein schon aus Nostalgiegründen auf, dann haben wir einen fetten Noctua, 120
Millimeter Gehäuse Lüfter, mit viel Staub dran, da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob ich
das aufheben soll, ich meine, der Lüfter ist zwar gut, ich habe aber absolut kein Anwendungszweck
für, Chat, weg oder behalten, eigentlich brauchen wir es nicht, weg, ja denke ich auch,
so, jetzt haben wir als nächstes noch einen Noctua Lüfter, Noctua, was ist das, 30 Millimeter,
25 keine Ahnung, LOL, guckt mal Leute, die komplette Noctua, komplette Noctua Geschichte
hier am Start, einmal Noctua, dann einmal Noctua, Low Noise Adapter und Extension Kabel, behalten,
die sind scheiß teuer, okay, Chat weiß Bescheid, behalten, excellent, excellent, mein Headset
spackt übrigens gerade rum, so, was haben wir denn hier, Super Micro, was ist das denn,
ist das irgendwie PCIe Express, einfach, okay jetzt muss ich mal kurz aufmachen, warum habe
ich sowas, ich habe nicht mal Super Micro Hardware, ja das ist eine Ryza Karte, Leute
ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern, dass ich das bestellt habe, warum sollte ich diese
Sache bestellt haben, ich habe keine Super Micro, ich habe überhaupt keinen Anwendungszweck
dafür, aber wahrscheinlich ist der Scheiß auch teuer, deswegen lohnt es sich eventuell
aufzunehmen, ob das auch in jedem anderen PCIe Express Slot geht, was meint ihr, magen
genommen ich nehme das jetzt und stecke das einfach auf Mainboard drauf, kommen dann aus
dem PCIe Express 16-fach auf einmal, keine Ahnung, 3-4-fach raus oder so, oder wie funzt
das, ach nee guck mal steht er da, 8-fach, 8-fach, 4-fach, 4-fach, das geht aber bestimmt
nur wenn das Mainboard das kann, ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert, okay ich würde
sagen für meinen Miningrechner ist das gut, den nicht vorhandenen Miningrechner, das
hebe ich mal auf, allein schon aus dem Grund, weil es wahrscheinlich teuer ist sowas zu
kaufen, hebe ich mal auf, so was haben wir denn sonst noch, ein Noctua Nippel, Kachibas,
der kann weg, den brauchen wir nicht, Noctua Wärmeleitpaste, die hebe ich mal auf, Wärmeleitpaste
kann man immer mal gebrauchen, oh Leute ich glaube die Wärmeleitpaste ist eh eingekrustet,
guck mal, da ist der Stöpsel vorne nicht drauf, ich mache jetzt einfach mal, ich mache
jetzt den Stöpsel vorne drauf und tue einfach so, als wäre das die ganze Zeit schon zu
gewesen, ne, hört das so, das sieht nicht richtig aus, das hat damit doch überhaupt
nichts zu tun oder, das passt da überhaupt nicht drauf, keine Ahnung, egal, ich packe
das jetzt einfach wieder ein und hebe das mal auf, so, aufheben, aufheben Champ, next,
noch mal eine Schelle, weil die kann jetzt aber echt weg, wo habe ich die für alles
Müll hier, zack, ähm, dann haben wir ein Lora Modul, irgendjemand hat schon richtig
erkannt im Chat, ich habe ein Lora Modul, was ich nie verwendet habe, sieht man auch
am Staub, der drauf ist, ich habe die gleichen Lora Moduls direkt an einem ESP angeschlossen,
diese Form habe ich nie verwendet, das ist glaube ich ein Header für einen Raspberry
Pi oder so, keine Ahnung, ich bin geneigt das wegzuschmeißen, weil ich überhaupt keinen
Anwendungszweck dafür habe, aber auf der anderen Seite, warum wegschmeißen, das nimmt
keinen Platz weg, oder, kommt noch mal eine Server Raum Tour, ich habe doch erst 2 gemacht,
der letzte ist aktuell, na, mal gucken, mal gucken, ähm, und dann haben wir noch, dann
haben wir noch 2 Raspberry Pis, Zero, wo irgendwas im Lüfter steckt, ich glaube nicht, dass
es eine Spoda ist, aber da steckt irgendwas im Lüfter, keine Ahnung was es ist, aber
ich vermute mal, der funktioniert noch, was sind das für welche überhaupt, das ist ein,
Raspberry Pi Zero W 1.1 und das hier ist ein Zero W 1.1, wer hätte das vermutet, ok,
die sind nice to have, also, die kann man auf jeden Fall noch gebrauchen, so und was
haben wir hier, ah, da habe ich mich schon gefragt, wo das hin ist, lull, das habe ich
gesucht, wie verrückt letztens, ich wusste, dass ich da noch ein zweites von habe, wartet
mal, ich zeige euch was das ist, das ist ein, das ist ein Automation, ein Automation Head
Mini für den Raspberry Pi, guck, das kann man hier oben drauf stecken, hier, deswegen
liegt der wahrscheinlich auch in der Kiste, wo die Raspberry Pis sind, weil ich mir gedacht
habe, das suche ich mal danach, kann man hier drauf stecken, und dann ist der Raspberry
Pi doof, weil der hat einen Lüfter, das war keine gute Idee, aber zumindest, was man hat,
das ist eigentlich ein megacooles, megacooler Header, megacooles Extension Board, du hast
ein Relay zum Schalten bis zu, glaube ich, 24 Volt, ja, Max hier, Max 24 Volt, 2 Ampere,
du hast ein Relay, du hast 3 Inputs, 3 Analog, man sieht es nicht richtig, 3 Analog Digitalkonverter,
wo du Spannung mit messen kannst, und 3 Outputs, und ein Relay, das ist richtig geil, also
wenn man Automatisierungs machen, wenn man irgendwelche Geräte steuern will oder so,
ist das wirklich Massive POG, der Header, wozu das ein Display hat, keine Ahnung, das
habe ich letztens wie verrückt gesucht, und ich habe es nicht gefunden, gut zu wissen,
dass das da ist, nice, das hebe ich alles auf, das wird alles aufgehoben, POG, POG OS, anscheinend
funktioniert das mit der Kamera jetzt, wie es aussieht, der einzige Unterschied ist,
ich habe Audioübertragung angemacht, nur dass ich die Audioübertragung wieder ausgeschaltet
habe, aber jetzt, das hat sich schon mal gelohnt, das habe ich wirklich wie Sau gesucht letztens,
ich habe es einfach nicht gefunden, kein Wunder, das lag irgendwo unter 2 Kartons, ok, nice,
ich bin begeistert, hat sich schon mal voll gelohnt, das hier anzugucken, jetzt habe ich
beim Abmachen, weil ich richtig grobmotorischer 3-Head Kollege bin, habe ich meine Raspberry
Pi Header verbogen, aber das ist ja kein Ding, biegen wir einfach wieder zurück, dann ist
es wieder halbwegs gerade, so, next, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, nächste Kiste, jawoll,
also kleine, kleine Kiste, aber ich weiß schon was es ist, das ist 16x16 LED, oh lag, Alter,
sag mal, das ist zu High Detail, das macht die Kamera nicht mit, da lags, guck mal Leute,
die Kamera kommt nicht mit, das ist zu viel für die Kamera, so rum gar kein Problem,
andersrum zu viel Details, 16x16 LED Matrix, Poggers, kann man sowas hier draus bauen,
so eine Lampe zum Beispiel, LED, RGB LED, stellts, gut, die hebe ich auf jeden Fall auf, so, nächste
Kiste, immer wieder kurz checken, dass ich keine Adresse leake oder so, ne, sieht nicht
so leaky aus, so, was ist denn hier alles drin, Audio, Bandbreite, Waves sind ja, aber
die Kamera geht nicht aus, so, was haben wir denn hier schönes, ein Ola ESP8266, glaube
ich, mit irgendeinem komischen USB Aufholstecker Adapter, wahrscheinlich hab ich das Ding gegrillt
und er kann direkt in die Hall of Shame Kiste, aber dennoch gehen würde ich mich wundern,
weil hier steckt man doch mal relativ schnell 12 Volt auf 5 Volt und dann ist MonkaS, so,
aber den heben wir erstmal auf, muss ich den nur testen, ob der noch funktioniert, so,
dann hab ich irgendein selbstgebasteltes Ding, ich glaube, Leute, ich weiß was das ist, das
ist mein selbstgebasteltes LoRa Gateway, genau, guck mal, da hinten kommt ja auch die Antenne
dran und irgendwo hier ist doch auch, hier ist ja auch die Antenne, guck mal da, ha,
MonkaS, hier, selbstgebasteltes LoRa Gateway, hab ich nicht im Einsatz, hab ich gebastelt
um zu lernen, wie es funktioniert und ja, jetzt ist es da, sonderlich viel Sinn hat
es nicht, aber ich behalte es mal, weil kann man bestimmt gebrauchen, ja, was ist LoRa,
LoRa ist ein Wireless, ist ein Wireless Protokoll, was für hohe Strecken ausgelegt ist, aber
niedrige Bandbreite, du kannst damit nur ein paar Bytes oder Bits teilweise übertragen,
aber es geht halt bis zu 2 Kilometer, auch durch Häuser durch und sowas, das ist sehr
praktisch für Sensoren und kleine Sachen, wird beispielsweise in der Landwirtschaft
auch öfters verwendet, für irgendwelche Regensensoren und Bewässerungsanlagen und
sowas, ok, das heben wir auf jeden Fall auf, dann haben wir, äh, Alter, Leute, was ist
das, guck mal, irgendwas totes, äh, Alter, lebt es, lebt es noch? Ich hab keine Ahnung,
was es ist, wo ist los, ja, ähm, so, was ist das, ne richtig oldschool Dual-Port Gigabit
Intel, Intel wahrscheinlich, ne, Broadcom, mit aus irgendwelchen Gründen, nicht, war
ich mit dem Slotplech nicht ganz so glücklich, guckt euch das zwar an, das hat anscheinend
nicht gepasst, ich kann mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern, aber das Slotplech war anscheinend
im Weg, wenn ich mir das so angucke hier unten, ja, Chat was sagt ihr behalten oder weg, ich
mein, ich werd nie wieder eine Dual-Port Gigabit Netzwerkkarte brauchen wahrscheinlich, zumal
es auch noch eine alte ist, die wahrscheinlich unnötig, unnötig heiß wird und Strom verbraucht,
dass die Karte, die falsch herum in der 4HE-Kiste war, durchaus möglich, dass die das ist,
ja, das kann die sein, die 4HE-Kiste hab ich auch schon ewig nicht mehr im Einsatz, was
ist ewig, 2 Jahre oder so, so, weg, ne, weg, hier, wo ist der alles Müll, alles Müll,
Achtung, ah, so, was haben wir denn hier, ein Shelley-Button, mit irgendwas was da drinnen
steckt, was steckt denn da drinnen, aha, hm, das ist glaub ich, das ist glaub ich noch
ein Laura-Modul, guck mal, glaub das ist noch ein Laura-Modul, was ich alles rumfliegen
hab, hm, das hebe ich mal auf, kann man bestimmt gebrauchen, Laura-Modul-Horter, ich, ich gehe
davon aus, ich hab den ganzen Kram wieder doppelt und dreifach, weil ihr kennt ja meine
Philosophie, ich bestelle nie einzelne Packen auf Amazon, ich bestell immer 3er, 5er oder
10er Packen, wahrscheinlich hab ich auch ein 3er, 5er oder 10er Packen von diesen Laura-Modulen
bestellt und dementsprechend hab ich da so viele von, so, was haben wir denn sonst hier,
was ist das, ein Shelley-Button, ist mir nicht bewusst, dass ich je ein Shelley-Button gekauft
habe und ich bin mir nicht mal sicher, was ein Shelley-Button überhaupt macht, ich vermute
mal, es ist ein Knopf, aber machen wir mal auf, keine Ahnung, ist auch schon bissl staubig,
ein Shelley-Button, gut, Button, oh, was war das, oh, Monka, Hochspannung, hm, ich hab
keine Ahnung, ist da ein ESP drin oder nicht, was macht man mit einem Shelley-Button überhaupt,
ich hab keine Ahnung, wir müssen mal kurz nachgucken, was man mit einem Shelley-Button
macht, habe keinen Plan, was man mit einem Shelley-Button macht, zeig mal her, ne, bleibst
du auf, Picture in Picture, genau, so, perfekt, so, Shelley, Shelley-Button, so, dafür brauche
ich also einen Shelley-Button, ach, Moment, muss man da noch ein Relay zusätzlich einbauen,
ist das ein Button, wo ich noch ein Relay zusätzlich reinmachen muss, ach so, aha, also sprich, eigentlich
müsste man, dass das funktioniert, hier noch ein Relay, hier noch ein Shelley-Relay einbauen,
also, dann nehme ich doch mal, wo habe ich denn jetzt den Shelley PM1 hin, da, guck
mal, da ist der Shelley PM1, das heißt, im Endeffekt würde das dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie
so funktionieren, guck mal, das passt ja auch so, als wäre das so gedacht, das passt erstaunlich
gut, die haben sich vielleicht ja fast dabei was gedacht, das ist ein Button und ein Relay,
hä, aber wo ist der Sinn davon, die Dinger sind eigentlich gedacht, dass man sie unterputz
einbaut, ok, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich nehme einfach zur Kenntnis, ich habe einen Shelley-Button
und ich kriege da Shelley PM nicht mehr raus, doch, ich habe einen Shelley-Button, ich weiß
nicht, wozu ich einen Shelley-Button habe, geschweige denn, was ich mit einem Shelley-Button
jetzt machen soll, aber ich habe halt einen Shelley-Button, nice, GG Eats, ein Shelley-Button,
nicht alles gibt, na gut, machen wir mal zu, so, das da kommt weg, wo ist der Müll, Müll,
zack, was haben wir als nächstes, Kabel, ein Erdnussbutter-Deckel, das ist wichtig,
den muss ich aufheben, ne Müll, Flup, eine Raspberry Pi Zero Cam habe ich, oh die sieht
da richtig wahnsinn verpackt aus, guckt euch das mal an, hä hä, jetzt sind die glatt und
sein Shelley-Shelley-Button, ja, bin auch richtig froh, dass ich festgestellt habe, ich habe
jetzt einen Shelley-Button, guckt mal hier, Chat Leak, ihr werdet, ihr werdet beobachtet,
wie macht man das auf hier, wie macht man das auf, wie macht man das auf, aha, aha,
aha, okay, fancy Verpackung, fancy Verpackung, eine Zero Cam, alles klar, warum ich die gekauft
habe, ich weiß es nicht mehr, aber, Pock, eine Raspberry Pi Zero Cam, aber schön verpackt
ist es, das muss man mal, muss man den mal lassen, heben wir auf jeden Fall auf, so und
jetzt sehe ich hier jede Menge sinnlose Jumper-Kabel, farbige Jumper-Kabel, kelbe Jumper-Kabel,
noch mehr farbige Jumper-Kabel, ne, normale SD-Karte, 64G normale SD-Karte, ich habe überhaupt
keine Geräte mehr, wo normale SD-Karten reinpassen, weg, weg, Pot, Müll, Samsung Solid State Drive,
alles klar, Müll, leere Hülle für Flora-Sensor, Müll, Alter, das ist schon ein bisschen staubig
hier drin, noch mehr Kabel, eine, guck mal, eine Löt-Spitze, für meine erste Lötstation,
den habe ich letztens gesucht, jetzt weiß ich auch wo er ist, noch eine Löt-Spitze,
haben wir noch mehr, aha, und noch ein Ersatz-Lötaufsatz-Schraubeteil, sehr schön, das muss ich aufheben, die habe ich
letztens nämlich gesucht, jetzt weiß ich auch wo sie sind, die waren in irgendeiner
Random-Kiste, auf dem Haufen, das war noch ein ESP8266 glaube ich, ja ok, Leute, was
ist das, ich habe keine Ahnung, jemanden planen was das ist, keine Ahnung, absolut kein
Schimmer, Dinger, ah, ein Ultraschall-Sensor, keine Kamera als Ultraschall, 16G-USB, das
ist ja uralt, und was ist das, es ist auf jeden Fall M2, aber es ist was, M2 auf USB,
oder was ist das, was ist das, chat, seid mal big brain, überlegt euch was das sein könnte,
ich muss mal die Musik neu starten, ich habe keine Ahnung was das ist, es ist auf jeden
Fall M2, und hier ist irgendwie Dreck drinnen, hartnäckiger Dreck, und es muss warm werden
weil es ist passiv gekühlt, also ich würde sagen, das ist, das ist M2 auf USB, aber gibt
es M2 auf USB, gibt es sowas überhaupt, also existiert das überhaupt was ich mir so überlege,
M2 auf USB, warum sollte das nicht existieren, M2 ist in zwei SATA-Lanes, also das kann schon
funktionieren, ok, der Dreck kommt mal weg hier, so, ich bin noch nicht fertig, ich habe
noch eine Kiste, und jetzt kommt noch die größte Kiste Leute, MonkaS, die größte
Kiste steht uns noch bevor, so, paar Sachen haben wir schon aussortiert, größte Kiste,
ja, Leute, Sekunde, ernsthaft abziehen, es ist jetzt sehr mutig, die Kiste steht nämlich
auf meinem Sitz, und ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich nicht dran denken werde, dass die
Kiste auf meinem Sitz steht, und ich werde mich hinsetzen, und mich in die Kiste setzen,
und mich übelst am Arsch verletzen, weil ich mich in irgendwas Spitzes reinsetze, ich
weiß es jetzt schon, ich call es jetzt schon, ok, also was haben wir denn hier, was haben
wir denn hier, was ist denn das, was ist das, mal gucken, dass da keine Adresse drauf steht,
was ist das, Eurozuleitung mit Schnur, Zwischenstecker, ah, das ist zum Netzteile anschließen, mit
einem Schalter, jetzt erkenne ich das, schau hier, Schalter, Euro, Stecker, Netzteile anschließen,
ok, das kann man auf jeden Fall mal gebrauchen, das bleibt hier, next, lull, da habe ich letztens
auch gesucht, mal Netzwerktester, einfach random in der Kiste drin, Netzwerktester,
wir können mal ausprobieren, wir testen mal den Netzwerktester, ob der noch funktioniert,
von der Idee her sollte jetzt, von der Idee her sollte jetzt eigentlich alles durchgängig
leuchten, gucken wir mal, ob die Batterie überhaupt noch funzt, und ist alles noch in Ordnung,
was sagt der Tester, so ein ganz primitiver Tester, ja, das scheint alles in Ordnung zu
sein, ok, Kabel funzt noch, sehr schön, off, Kabeltester, POG, kann man gebrauchen, aufheben,
erstmal den Small Access Point wieder fixen, so, na, wer hat schon die MAC Adresse kopiert,
zu spät, nicht dass irgendwas passieren würde, ach du Scheiße, alter Leute, ich hab die Ausgrabung
aus Griechenland entdeckt, so gratis persönlich, das muss von den alten Griechen kommen, lull,
dass ich so einen Teil überhaupt noch hab, das ist, hast du ein Museum ausgeräumt, ne,
ich hab bei mir Kisten ausgeräumt, ich hab halt hier ziemlich viel Zeug rumstehen gehabt,
jetzt wo ich Zeit hab, räum ich mal auf, ok, das ist keine Ahnung, von 1998 oder so, das
ist uralt, lasst mal kurz hinten drauf gucken, hier, TELEDAT, TELEDAT USB 2, AB, das ist
ne ISDN Telefonanlage, guck mal hier, TISDN, nicht einfach nur ISDN, TISDN, TISDN B Kanal
1, 2, PC Daten, TNet Box, null sogar mit Anrufbeantworter noch, das hätte damals auch
keiner gedacht, das hätte damals auch keiner gedacht, dass analog Telefon ISDN überlebt,
damals war ISDN der neueste Shit und heute gibt es das nicht mal mehr, Sachen gibt es,
das hebe ich auf jeden Fall auf, das ist so alt, das ist glaube ich 1998, 1999, also
das ist richtig uralt das Ding und ich wette es funst immer noch, man sieht auch, dass
es schon ziemlich gelb ist, das T steht für toll, ja, dieser Kommentar wurde ihnen gesponsert
von der Telekom, das ist nicht aus dem Raucherhaushalt, ich hab nie geraucht, aber mit der Zeit werden
diese Dinger gelb, oh was haben wir denn hier, Leute, keine Werbung, ich werde nicht mehr
gesponsert von denen, aber ich hab noch eine Tüde, da ist Zeug drin, ich vermute, ich vermute,
das ist Gamescom Zeug, Gamescom 2014 oder sowas wahrscheinlich noch, oder so wie, lasst
mal kurz checken, lasst mal kurz abchecken, was haben wir denn hier, ich muss nur mal kurz
schauen, dass da nicht irgendwas mit Adresse drin ist, nee anscheinend nicht, ok, also
gucken wir mal, was haben wir denn hier, also was ist das, ein T-Shirt, ein T-Shirt und
es war ein T-Shirt für, eh, jemanden planen was das sein soll, ah, da steht der Titel
steht auf der anderen Seite, oh, das ist das, lul, das ist das eingestellte, dieser eingestellte
Microsoft-Zelda-Fake, der nie rausgekommen ist, das hat ja schon Raritätsfaktor, Alter,
Rare Parrot, das ist dieses Xbox-Zelda, was sie eingestellt haben, alles klar, ok, ich
wusste nicht, war mir nicht bewusst, dass ich da für ein T-Shirt hab, aber gut, ehm,
Next, was haben wir als nächstes drin, Müll, kommt weg, ein G2A-Hemd, das brauchen wir
glaube ich nicht mehr, dann haben wir noch ein, ach guck mal, ein Quantum Break, Quantum
Break-T-Shirt, das ist nice, XL, da passe ich sogar rein, Peppo Fett, Quantum Break-T-Shirt,
dann haben wir eine, keine Ahnung, Deus Ex, Mankind Divided, Adam Jensen, das art sich
aus, Alter, das hat sich aus, Adam Jensen, das ist gerade voll auf meine Verlängerung
fürs Headset drauf gefallen, was ist denn da drin, ach, irgendeine komische Figur, ok,
das brauchen wir wirklich keinen Menschen, ok, Next, das allerwichtigste Leute überhaupt,
was jeder schonmal haben wollte, ein G2A-Pay-Schlüsselanhänger, ganz ganz wichtig, Leute, hier, wer hat noch
nicht G2A-Gutscheincode, ist aber wahrscheinlich schon eingelöst, geh ich mal von aus, bam,
G2A-Gutscheincode, auf gehts, Next, ok, ein G2A-USB-Stick, Leute, ich kann euch sagen,
den mach ich nicht in meinen Rechner rein, und das war's, ok, ja, hebe ich mal als Andenken
auf, braucht man zwar nicht, aber why not, und leg ich das jetzt mal hin, irgendwo hier
neben hin, bam, ok, weiter gehts, weiter gehts, was haben wir hier, die Figur kostet 30 Euro
auf Ebay, easy money, äh, was, chat, was ist die Frage, das da hinten, das ist ein
WLAN-Access-Point, ein ganz kleiner Mikrotik-Access-Point hier, der da, Schmoll-Access-Point, den hab
ich zum testen hier, weil der halt schön klein und kompakt ist, so, was haben wir
hier als nächstes, äh, Probe-3D-Druckzeug, das hebe ich mal auf, ist aber sehr unspektakulär,
das brauchen wir nicht, ähm, oh, was haben wir denn hier, oh, fahrer, es fällt runter,
heck wait, nicht runterfallen, was haben wir denn hier, guck mal da, noch ein originalverpackter
Mikrotik-Routerboard, ok, was ist denn das für einer, RB 260 GSP, ah, ich weiß was
das ist, das ist noch gar nicht so, das ist noch gar nicht so alt, das kann ich mich dran
erinnern, wo ich das gekauft habe, das hab ich gekauft für PoE im Keller, aber, ähm,
der konnte nicht das richtige PoE für meinen Keller, der konnte glaube ich nur 24V PoE
oder irgendwas, er konnte irgendwas, was ich, was nichts gebracht hat im Keller auf jeden
Fall, ein Routerboard, genau, den hebe ich auf jeden Fall auf, den haben wir immer mal
gebrauchen, Routerboard, Leute wie findet ihr so Streams, wollen wir das öfters mal
machen, Max packt alles Zeug aus und sagt was dazu, weil ich hab noch jede Menge Zeug
was ich aufräumen muss, ich kann bestimmt noch 3 Streams in dieser Richtung machen,
ja, gut nice, oh, was ist hier los, warum ist das jetzt immer Fullscreen, Fullscreen, jawoll,
so was haben wir hier als nächstes, was haben wir hier als nächstes, BAM, oh Adressen,
Stells, ah ne, nur, nur China-Chinesen Zeug, ok, ich hab noch mal Glück gehabt, nur China-Chinesen
Zeug, wobei es gar nicht China-Chinesen Zeug, es ist, Eschborner Landstraße, Frankfurter
Mine, null, alles klar, was es ist, ich habe keine Ahnung, es sind angeblich, Way in Top,
10 Stücke, Mikro, U, I, Y, USB, Netzteil, Steckbrett, keine Ahnung, was ich mir darunter
vorstellen soll, jetzt geht es schon mal richtig auf, eh, eh, ok, was, genau, ok, ok, ok,
Mikro-USB, ah, ok, ich glaub jetzt versteh ichs, guck mal, das ist einfach nur zum Durchschleifen
von der USB-Stromversorgung, das ist alles, joa, kann man mal gebrauchen, why not, pack
mal mal wieder ein, ich hätte es vielleicht nicht so zerreißen sollen, oh, und rein damit
wieder, zack, rein, rein, rein und zu, so, also was haben wir als nächstes noch, hier
ist noch ein bisschen was drin Leute, MonkaS, was ist denn das, Brek, Brek, Brekiva, Brekiva,
das ist bestimmt ein gekommenes Produkt, Brekiva, Krimptools, aber für was, ach, das ist,
das ist das A der Endhülsen Set, oder, schaut mal, ja, das ist das A der Endhülsen Set,
jetzt weiß ich wieder, was das ist, ok, eines der sinnlossten Dinger, die ich je gekauft
habe, ich verwende nie A der Endhülsen, komplett, komplett useless, deswegen hab ich es auch
nie vermisst, brauch ich net, wo die Pakete herkommen, ich hab hier total viel Zeug stehen
gehabt und hab jetzt endlich mal aufgeräumt und alles durchgegangen, was da abgeht, braucht
jeder, so, was haben wir denn hier als nächstes, aha, Leute, ich stell da grade Five Head einen
Zusammenhang her, zwischen den Gerät, zwischen D, zwischen der Gerät und zwischen der Gerät
von eben, wer, wer, wer kann, stellt noch Five Head Zusammenhang her, wo ist es, wo
ist es, wo, wo ist das M2 Ding von eben, Moment, ah, wo ist das M2 Ding von eben, es ist weg,
Leute, Säck, Säck, wir müssen das M2 Ding von eben suchen, wo ist das M2 Ding von eben,
wo ist das M2 Ding von eben, wo ist es hin, hab ich das weggeschmissen, hab ich das weggeschmissen,
okay, da muss ich jetzt nochmal zum Müll, da muss ich jetzt kurz gucken, hab ich das
weggeschmissen, ja, chat, ihr wisst das besser als ich, ich weiß es nochmal, okay, Sekunde,
Müll, aha, jetzt ergibt das Sinn, guckt doch mal da, guckt doch mal da, guckt doch
mal da, oder auch andersrum, oh nee, fuck, ich hab's grad falsch rum reingedrückt, keck,
wait, so, guck doch mal, das ist ein M2, was es nicht alles gibt, Mann, das ist ein M2
auf Dualport Netzwerk, warum ich sowas hab, weil ich dachte ich brauch's mal wahrscheinlich,
keine Ahnung, bin unschlüssig, wozu das gut sein sollte, aber jetzt ergibt das Sinn, nice,
das heißt jetzt schmeißen wir es nicht weg, jetzt heben wir es auf, grade nochmal richtiges
Upgrade gekriegt, von weggeschmeißen zu, so, oh, das nächste sieht ja sehr hochwertig
aus, guck mal, eine China-Chinesen PCI Express Verlängerung, guck mal, für Bitcoin und Litecoin,
für irgendwelche Miner, das sieht hier unten mit dem Klebeband, mit dem Klebeband sieht
es auch sehr sehr hochwertig verarbeitet aus, funktioniert das M2 to Ethernet, ja, das funktioniert,
wenn das ein PCI Express Lane ist, also super hochwertiges, super mega hochwertige PCI Express
Verlängerung, die funktioniert wahrscheinlich aber richtig, die schmeißen wir weg, Leute,
das brauch ich nie wieder, das Ding, so, aha, was haben wir denn hier, ja, guck du mal an,
das hab ich irgendwann mal anscheinend bekommen, und das ist dann in den großen Haufen an Kisten,
ich hab hier Wonders, Xbox One, Mann, USK 18, WTF, warum ist das USK 18, ach, wahrscheinlich
wegen Perfect, wie heißt das, Perfect Dark Zero, wie ist das, mit der da, wahrscheinlich
wegen Perfect Dark ist das, ok, interessant, ich hab eine Rare Replay Collection, gut zu
wissen für eine Konsole, wo ich nicht mal weiß, wo sie gerade steht, die ich quasi
nie an hatte, aber Rare Replay Collection am Start, heb ich mal auf, warum nicht, was
haben wir hier, guck du mal da, eine USB, USB 3.2 Gen 1x1 x.4 Schnittstelle auf 2,5G,
also Pepega USB Standards, 2,5G, Netzwerkadapter für USB, das war mal ursprünglich USB 3.1
wahrscheinlich, ja, USB 3.2 x.x 420, USB 69 x.x, ja, das ist gut, das hebe ich auf
jeden Fall auf, was haben wir hier, Wandtaster, das ist wahrscheinlich sowas wie der Shelley
Button, das packe ich jetzt nicht aus, das ist langweilig, oh, letztens haben wir erst
noch drüber gesprochen Leute, guck du mal da, ein Switch-Bot, ihr kennt mich, ich hab
bestimmt für den 5er Pack bestellt damals, ein Switch-Bot, Poggers-Bot, jetzt kann ich
euch den Switch-Bot auch mal live im Einsatz zeigen, Zack wir machen mal schnell auf, wird
man eigentlich auf Twitch gebannt, wenn ich mich jetzt aus Versehen an der Hand verletze
beim Aufmachen, weil das ist ja dann quasi Selbstverletzung und so, das darf man ja nicht
streben, ist aber keine Absicht, ein Switch-Bot, oh, ok, ich soll das hier rausziehen sagen
sie, pull, remove before use, bam, pull und jetzt, oh nu, es bewegt sich nicht, brauche
ich jetzt die App dafür, dass es sich bewegt, geht das, geht das, geht bestimmt nicht ohne
Appe und man kann es auch nicht, nicht so irgendwie aktivieren, kann man das aufmachen?
Ah guck mal, Batterie-Stells, ja die machen wir, die Batterie machen wir mal raus, weil
ansonsten, wir machen hier einfach wieder diesen komischen Streifen davor, keine Ahnung
ob der jetzt richtig sitzt, aber, oh und wieder rein damit und dieses Zeug auch rein damit,
ich kann es euch jetzt nicht zeigen, weil ich die App nicht habe und auch keinen Bock
habe, die App aufzusetzen, oh rein, zack, Switch-Bot, zu, gut, den heben wir auf jeden
Fall auf, dann, Achtung ihr werdet beobachtet Chat, habe ich noch eine Kamera, das kann
ich mir noch dran erinnern, die habe ich bestellt, weil irgendjemand im Chat gesagt hat, die
würde sich gut eignen für meinen Einsatzzweck, aber danach habe ich festgestellt, man braucht
die App, um sein WLAN Passwort in die China Cloud zu sünken und dann hatte ich keinen
Bock die zu verwenden, sünkt doch mein WLAN Passwort nicht in die China Cloud, also irgendwas
ist auch mal gut, so und als letztes, auch was, was ich schon eine ganze Weile gesucht
habe, da bin ich froh, dass ich das wieder gefunden habe, ein, das habe ich auch schon
Jahre Jahrzehnte, ein Super Smart Joy, das ist für originale Super Nintendo Adapter
auf USB, USB 1.0 oder so ist das noch, das ist mein originaler Super Nintendo Adapter,
von 1900 erkennt man das, ne steht aber was drauf, ne, von 1995 oder so, spiel damit mal
Battlefield, ja hoffentlich, damit hast du wahrscheinlich weniger Probleme als mit dem
aktuellen Maus Support, richtig nice, dass ich das wieder gefunden habe, das behalte
ich definitiv, das kommt nicht weg, das kommt nicht weg, so jetzt muss ich gerade mal den
anderen Kram wieder einsortieren, von dem was ich behalten will, guck mal her, zack,
erzelt like…
TAPO C200 IP Customfirmware Ah nice, gleich mal checken.
Customfirmware, wo ist die Customfirmware Leute?
Ne, das ist keine Customfirmware, das ist einfach nur Research, das ist keine Customfirmware,
das ist einfach nur Research, wie man diese Software eventuell exploiten kann für Customfirmware,
das ist keine Customfirmware. So Leute, mehr habe ich nicht, das war alles,
und witzigerweise das meiste, unter anderem auch so komische Dinger, wie so ein HDMI-Kabel,
keine Ahnung, davon habe ich 30.000 Stück. Ach Moment, jetzt erkenne ich das ja erst,
das ist kein HDMI-Kabel, das ist Display-Port auf HDMI.
Ok, das ist doch sinnvoll aufzuheben. Jetzt den Desktop aufräumen, kein Bedarf,
der ist gut so, wie er ist. Ne, jetzt spiele ich keinen Battlefield mehr.
Müll, weg. Exzellent. Ok, ja Leute, was machen wir jetzt?
Gibt es noch irgendwelche High-IQ-Questions, die ich übersehen habe?
Du wirst lachen, sowas habe ich auf meinem alten Desktop, also auf meinem normalen Haupt-Main-Rechner-Desktop,
da habe ich Ordner old1, old2, old3, da kommt das einmal im Jahr, kommt der Desktop-Inhalt
rein, von den Sachen, die ich da nicht brauche. Aber auch nur, weil Windows so langsam wird,
wenn der Desktop zu voll wird. Noch das Linux-Challenge-Video schauen, stimmt
das wollten wir heute morgen schauen, ich bin nicht dazu gekommen. Schauen wir mal.
Linux-Challenge. Linux-Gaming-Challenge, kannst vergessen.
Try to do simple tasks on Linux-Lol. Also, da ist doch die Linux-Master-Race-Leute
bestimmt am flamen, oder? Weil er nicht sagt, Linux ist das beste, mit Linux kann man alles
machen, Linux for the win. Wenn du das nicht sagst, wirst du gehatet von den Ultra-Linux-Fanboys.
Ich glaube, das ist langweilig. Ich glaube nicht, dass das analysiert spannend
ist. Das gucken wir nicht. Chat, es ist 20 Uhr. 20 Uhr ist zwar nicht
schon spät, aber ich habe alles durch, was ich durchprobieren wollte. Danke für die
ganzen Subs, Leute. Ich habe die Hälfte wieder nicht gesehen, weil ich so am gucken war.
Adnock hat, Wishart hat gesubbt, der Ritter Ross, der Karlsson hat gesubbt, Grüne Pizza
hat gesubbt, der Lollmann, der Mark LDM, Kengin hat wiedergesubbt, 13 Jahre, jawoll.
Habe ich alles wieder nicht richtig mitbekommen. Haki hat gesubbt, alles übersehen. Danke
Leute für die ganzen Subs. Keine Döner gekessen, exellent. Na gut Leute, dann würde ich sagen,
ich gehe jetzt off. Zwar nicht bettge, aber ich gehe off. Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Wir sehen uns morgen oder übermorgen oder die nächsten Tage wieder. Offge, genau. Bis
dann, machts gut. See you.